Ці кадри японських міст Хіросіма й Нагасакі
часто з’являються у теленовинах через зростання напруги
між США та Північною Кореєю.
Світ як ніколи близький до ядерної війни, відзначають оглядачі.
Саме тому не дивно,
що з понад двохсот осіб та ста організацій Нобелівський комітет
вирішив вручити премію миру цьогоріч
саме організації "Міжнародна кампанія
за відмову від ядерної зброї" - АйКен.
50 сучасних ядерних боєголовок можуть вбити 200 мільйонів людей.
Це приблизно населення всієї Бразилії.
Але нині у світі є двадцять три тисячі ядерних боєголовок.
Організація отримує нагороду за те, що своєю роботою
привернула увагу до
катастрофічних гуманітарних наслідків
будь-якого застосування ядерної зброї.
І за її неймовірні зусилля у досягненні
Угоди про заборону такої зброї.
Йдеться про Угоду, яку ухвалили в ООН сьомого липня цього року.
Завдяки зусиллям ICAN за неї проголосували
122 країни.
Але ратифікували поки лише більше півсотні країн.
Угода забороняє розробку, випробування, зберігання,
придбання, транспортування та використання
ядерної зброї. А також
вимагає утилізувати вже наявну в країні ядерну зброю.
Втім, володарі найбільших запасів ядерної зброї у світі –
Росія, США, Франція -
проголосували, але не квапляться приєднуватися
до цієї Угоди. І це найбільше засмучує цьогорічних
лауреатів премії миру.
Вони недостатньо швидко рухаються до розброєння. Ядерна зброя не є
зброєю легальної війни. Закони війни
говорять про те, що не можна стріляти по цивільних.
Але ядерна зброя призначена уражати саме їх.
Вона призначена стерти з лиця землі цілі міста.
Це не припустимо і володіння ядерною зброєю
не може більше мати виправдання.
Отримання Нобелю миру, на думку представників ICAN,
допоможе ще більше привернути увагу людства до цієї
проблеми. А також збільшіть тиск
на уряди країн, що володіють ядерною зброєю.
ICAN об’єднує неурядові організації з близько ста країн світу.
І отримає, окрім диплома нобелівського лауреата,
ще і винагороду у майже мільйон євро.